hi everyone welcome back my name is
mehul and in this video let's just go
ahead and discuss
what should be your first programming
language
if you're somebody who has just gotten
introduced to programming computer
science
and all the fun stuff how should you
even start i mean that's the biggest
question right because you don't want to
pick the wrong thing to master and then
master it and then realize you pick the
wrong thing that will be the absolute
horror so let's just go ahead and
dive deep into what are some of the
things you should consider when picking
a programming language
especially when it's your first one
because that could make or break
a lot of things for you all right so to
answer this question we have to go a
little bit
deep into your context because this
question is not
as simple as just a boolean thing
you should learn this or you should not
learn this this depends on
what you are trying to do right now at
this moment
there are a lot of ways you could be
introduced to programming in general
whether it's it could be
your university for example i guess
that's the most common way it could be
your curiosity
it could be your friends it could be
anything anywhere you might have seen
code for the first time and you might
have wondered hmm
i want to do something around that take
a note of that moment
for me that moment was when i was trying
to create
websites on blogger.com and i wanted to
add a subscriber's widget to my
website that evening that day that was
the defining moment for me
to actually learn html and css as
one of my first programming languages
some people hate the fact that html some
people call html programming languages
but that does not matter here but let me
know in the comments what you think
about that
but the fact is for me the context
at that point was i wanted to add a
subscribe
widget to my blog the step number one is
figure out
what's your context why are you even
trying to
get into programming what's your gateway
what's the gateway reason you are trying
to get into programming
and your gateway reason would most
likely be an industry
level skill set somehow for example for
me
subscribe to us widget actually required
me to learn web development for you if
you're interested in
robots for example that is another
industry where you program robots and
how
what frameworks you use and all that
stuff if you're interested in
automating and machine learning and
stuff like this that is
ml and ai is another industry in itself
if hacking feels cool to you for example
then cyber security is another industry
in itself although it has divisions into
web security and reverse engineering and
all that stuff but
it's still an industry so figure out
your industry
figure out why you are actually trying
to get into programming
once you have your context once you have
your reason why are you even trying to
get into programming
still i would not recommend just jumping
onto a language
still hold on try to figure out what
goes
into that industry for example if you're
trying to get into web
development if you're trying to create
websites somehow if you want to create
pages
so in that case i would recommend
starting off not with c
not with c plus plus not with java not
with python but actually start with
htmls and css
or and javascript right it makes sense
because if you're learning about c
plus plus and you learn about pointers
and you learn about
sockets and you learn about a little bit
of operating system
management as well and you're trying to
get into web development
then it makes no sense to learn c plus
plus sure
some people might argue that that could
set up you for fundamentals
but that is it that's all it will do and
you can
trust me you can learn the fundamentals
using a language like javascript as well
although it's a little bit more
forgiving and people love to hate about
the fact that
it allows mistakes and stuff but i have
been through that journey a lot of
people have been through that journey
and i believe it's a completely fine
path if you choose to follow the right
resources and the right people
a language is bad because developers
code it in a bad way
and of course the language sometimes
does allow a lot of
loose sendbacks as well but javascript
has come a long way
and i believe it is a good option to
start as your first language
if you're trying to get into a language
if you're trying to get into a space
which requires that the first one being
web development then of course you might
be somebody who is trying to create a
mobile
application for example then it makes
much more sense for you to start with a
language like
java or kotlin or swift depending on
which operating system or which
mobile phone you want to create
applications for but
it does not make sense to start with
let's say
c plus plus again i'll just keep on
targeting c plus
because the application for c plus plus
actually
is there but it's for more optimized and
you know driver-based code these days
compared to
just practical application i mean it
does has that but it will take you a
long time to actually build something
meaningful
with a low level language not a low
level a high level language but
something which is more sophisticated
than the alternatives like python or
javascript
all right so to summarize what we have
first of all
choose the context why you're trying to
learn what you're trying to learn
number one whether it's mobile
application web development
ml ai data science cyber security
that's what you have to figure out
number two figure out what
works in these industries what are the
common languages what is the common tool
what are some common things which you
need to learn
and then get started with those things
alone right it can help you if you have
just taken a python course
or if you have taken a c plus course but
if you're somebody who's extremely new
it's almost always okay to start
with the language in that space that is
completely fine
all right so what about those people who
are still who have made it till this
point in this video and they are still
confused
on what to choose for you what i would
say is
just start with python or javascript
just toss a coin pick a python or a
javascript side
and whatever lands start with that
because these two
are extremely easy languages to start
with
they have tons of content online they
have tons of support online
and although it's possible that you
might be
might struggle a little bit in the way
how to actually take advanced steps
what to do next when you're done but for
the starting part at least
you will be able to start even if you
are a little bit more skeptical towards
javascript side that's fine because
javascript has of course has a loose
syntax so python is also a good start in
terms of a general purpose language
start with that start with something i
mean don't just
put out a lot of excuses i'm researching
that i'm researching this that's fine
but a lot of things when you realize
even if you complete a language you will
realize a lot of things these things are
transferable
to the next one if you learn about
python you're not just learning about
python
but you're learning about variables
you're learning about functions you're
learning about assignments you're
learning about
operators mathematical operators things
like these and a lot of these things can
be just transferred to javascript and
similarly for c
plus if you're learning for variables
and assignments in c plus you can
transfer
these to other languages like c or java
or things like these so the important
part here
is to actually first of all i would
recommend trying to figure out
the context why you are learning taking
a look at the tools there
what are the common tools and then
starting with those instead of just
randomly learning but if you're still
unsure
just start with python or javascript and
make your way from there
make your way from there as in once you
cover that language
see how you can use that in your
context in your original context to
build something
because when you are building something
that is when your true
test happens what you have learned your
true test is not passing a couple of
quiz questions
it's not about passing an interview it's
about actually
making use of your knowledge in real
world because that's that's what matters
at the end of the day
so i hope this video helped you in order
to figure out what should be your first
language
if you have still no idea like i said
just start with javascript if you do
have idea
whether it's javascript whether it's
python whether it's ruby whether it's
php
whether it's uh c plus plus make sure
you leave a like
comment and tell me what your first
language will be or what your first
language
was and if you have any advice for
people in order to start
high schoolers people who are still in
college in order to start with a
language
do let us know in the comments what you
think that is all for this video
and i'm gonna see you in the next one
really soon
[Music]